pixelmon was sold as the greatest nft
game ever they promised the largest and
the highest quality game the nft space
has ever seen that's the promise that
investors spent 70 million dollars on
the hope for a virtual metaverse where
you can play with friends battle and
trade pixelmon and more the founder was
anonymous which is always a good sign
this guy cyber he told people pixelmon
is the next blue chip this is financial
advice don't do your own research and oh
boy did people listen zero research was
done and 70 million dollars was raised
at a price of roughly ten thousand
dollars per jpeg now what do they have
to show for it well we've been waiting
patiently here at coffeezilla and
finally the team revealed their nft
artwork who is that pixelmon
[Music]
i assume they modeled him after the
average nft investor and brace
yourselves
because it gets much worse bulbor
uh you know get it a a light bulb with
with eyes ten ten thousand dollars guys
ten thousand dollars and also we have
bormon now borman i've gotta tell you
guys is my favorite because he has the
same expression i had when i realized
people paid ten thousand dollars for
this
now off rip let's be honest with
ourselves this looks bad actually that's
being polite it looks horrible we've
regressed in time this looks worse than
gen one pokemon back in 1998. i mean
need i remind you back then you could
spend 30 on a finished game that you
could play with your friends now in 2022
nfts have come out and people are trying
to charge you 10 000 for an unfinished
game where the only friend you can play
with
is kevin and nobody likes kevin now
unsurprisingly pixelmon have already
lost 90 of their value which is still
way overpriced but many people might be
wondering how did this happen how does
this keep happening every week i feel
like we're reading about the same story
and as the internet detective i'm here
to explain it for you guys but i also
have to credit two guys zack bxt and
kobe on twitter who helped document this
meltdown go give those guys a follow but
now let's answer the question
what went wrong most of pixelmon's
success is because of a game demo that
was given before launch which looked
kinda good there wasn't a lot to it the
demo lasted like a minute and was only a
basic world but you have to understand
in the world of nfts even the smallest
amount of effort makes you seem like
you're the next mark zuckerberg which is
why it basically sold out despite some
noticeable flaws but given how ambitious
this project is you might wonder who's
behind this who's the founder who's
going to execute on this dream of
pokemon meets metaverse meets nfts
because as the saying goes it's the man
that makes the project and in this case
that man is a boy his name is martin and
he's 21 years old and in charge of 70
million dollars now we have to pause
here a second and appreciate 70 million
dollars that's
aaa game funding like you could get a
blizzard or activision game with that
and instead it's been spent on someone
with zero experience which i think
personally is an interesting experiment
because already i'm playing 70 million
dollar games made by competent people
and i hate them i'm kind of curious what
happens when someone who doesn't know
what they're doing gets in charge of
that 70 million i mean could it get
worse well according to early reports
yes for example this investor minted his
nft and literally got nothing he didn't
even get a kevin he got the minecraft
default cue and i've got to say right
now that's probably the only thing i
would have paid ten thousand dollars to
see the look on this guy's face after
seeing this concept art and getting this
he says quote thanks pixelmon i got an
invisible character worst mint of my
life at least give me a character i
can't even give away this now i know
that looks bleak but to be fair to the
pixelmon team they're saying that look
that's just the nfts the actual game is
going to be way better because they're
going to outsource that work to an
actual game studio magic media but if
this is their plan to outsource the work
i've got to say things are looking
pretty bleak i mean it's kind of like
being relieved theranose hired a blood
scientist to help make the tech work
it's not exactly a vote of confidence
that all the actual work is being
outsourced i mean the problem remains
the leadership the massive promises just
having tons of money to throw at the
problem doesn't mean you'll succeed
millions of startups get funded and fail
every year what makes the difference is
the idea and the leader which in this
case are both mediocre but of course you
might be thinking wait a second there is
another option the founder could just
return the money which investors asked
about can we be refunded the response is
classic crypto no that's not how the
space works over promise under deliver
that's how this space works right so you
might be wondering if no refund is
coming how does a 21 year old with no
experience build something no one's ever
done before well the answer is simple
you just go steal work from people
who've done it before see apparently
some of the sneak peeks of pixelmon were
actually just stock assets on the unity
store like this snake which can be found
for
159 dollars here's another example of
the founder looking for this baby dragon
he wants to use another guy sources it
and he says oh yeah haha bought that
yesterday now i want to be clear the
pixelmon team claims they didn't use
these assets for the actual nfts but
instead paid artists to modify these
assets slightly which isn't really that
much better especially considering that
some of the artists that were hired
didn't even know their work would be
sold as nfts for example this guy who
designed some of the dragons said i
don't actually endorse nfts because
exactly this other people get rewards
for the artist's work and he's right he
made six thousand dollars designing
dragons for pixelmon and pixelmon
made 70 million dollars
now not only that remember that this
whole thing is supposed to be getting
designed by some
aaa game studio magic media that
actually has the experience but so far
that isn't what's happened at all in
fact in some of the models you can see
upwork which is a freelance website
listed in the save file so apparently
part of the 70 million dollar game you
guys just bought is being designed by
freelancers who might not even know if
their work is going to be used as nfts
and all this just shows the inexperience
of the founder he's rushing around
trying to fulfill impossible
expectations and the result is exactly
what you'd expect a mangled mess of
stock assets freelance work and botched
art but to be clear i don't think the
founder holds all the blame here
pixelmon doesn't seem like a rug pull
the way a lot of nfts are it's a
terrible investment absolutely but
that's not the same thing as a scam
where people just run away with the
money that actually hasn't happened yet
instead the situation is you just have a
21 year old inexperienced developer with
a 70 million dollar war chest and i
think that's kind of on the investors
they're the ones who put millions of
dollars into a game with zero
credibility and that isn't out yet and
honestly i don't think there's a good
answer for this i mean i think it's on
the people who wanted to get rich and
decided to gamble because it's fine if
you want to do that but when you lose
it's kind of on you now of course i'm
sympathetic to you guys so i'm not going
to leave you guys hanging if you lost
money on pixelmon i do want to help you
guys out with a friendly tip there's
actually an open world game called
pixelmon as well that is out today you
don't have to wait for it and believe it
or not you can play it even if you're
broke because of pixelmon because
well this pixelmon is free and comparing
the two a free game which is already out
to a 70 million dollar disaster i think
the only reaction to have here is this
so that's basically it pump the stock by
liking and subscribing see in the next
one